When you're troubleshooting a computer,
it's common to sit down at a machine
that you've never seen before and be
expected to know everything there is to
know about the internals of that device.
One of the ways that you can get a quick
overview of this device configuration is
by running the system information
utility. If you'd like to do this
quickly, you can simply run MSinfo
32.exe.
The first is hardware resources where we
can view how much memory is in the
system, what DMA settings have been
configured, any interrupts, and any
conflicts with any of those settings. We
also have a section for components. So,
if you'd like to see what the display
settings and network configurations are,
you can find them under that category.
And lastly, we have software
environment, which shows us what drivers
are installed, any print jobs that may
be pending, and any running tasks that
are configured in our system. Here is
the system information utility on my
computer and you can see those three
categories for hardware resources,
components, and software environment.
Before we get into those categories
though, you'll notice there is a system
summary which gives us a nice overview
of how this system is configured. We can
see the operating system name and
version. We can identify processor
details, the BIOS config. We know
exactly what device is the boot device
from here. And we can see information
about the available memory and file
space on this computer. Under the
hardware resources, let's click the plus
sign to expand this section. You can see
information about any conflicts or
sharing problems that we have on this
computer. None are listed on my current
device. Any DMA or direct memory access
devices, nothing there. We got forced
hardware, IO settings, IRQs for
interrupts, and then the memory
configuration on this computer. Under
the components category, there are a
number of different options available.
For example, you can view sound device
information. We'll expand the network
settings to view the adapter, the
protocol, and the Windock details. You
can also view storage information from
here. There's information about the
drives on your system, the detailed disk
information, and any other IDE or
information about a SATA drive. And at
the bottom, we have software
environment. Let's expand that category.
And we can see information about our
system drivers. And there are a lot of
system drivers on your Windows computer.
Information about any print jobs that
may be pending. We currently have no
print jobs in our queue. and details
about services, program groups, and
other software information. There's
nothing inside of this program that you
can change or modify, but this does
provide you with a quick way to find
details about this system without
digging into multiple operating system
utilities or different configuration
parameters.
In previous videos, we've looked at the
real-time analysis available inside of
Task Manager and the long-term analysis
that's available inside of performance
monitor. There's also a utility called
resource monitor that combines that
realtime view with detailed statistics.
You can see this listed as CPU, disk,
network, and other categories. You can
see that this shows an overview of how
your system is performing. CPU
information, memory categories, disk and
network. If you want to run resource
monitor, you can simply choose that from
your search option or you can type in
restmon
res.exe. As you can see, there is a lot
of detail available inside of resource
monitor. And this overview page
separates it out by CPU, disk, network,
and you can see a breakdown of
individual services running in each of
those separate categories. If you want a
more detailed view of each of those
categories, you can choose that option
on the top tabs to break down
information about the individual CPUs
and how they're performing, information
about the memory used inside of your
system, how much drive or storage
information is being utilized at this
moment, and information about how much
of our network we're using. If you're
trying to get detailed information about
a specific application and what it may
be using with a specific resource,
you're able to view that inside of
resource
monitor. The process for starting
Windows is very similar across multiple
systems. You power on the computer, you
can see a splash screen for Windows pop
up, and then there's usually a login
prompt. There's also a lot of
customization that you can do with what
happens behind the scenes when Windows
is starting up. And one easy way to set
these parameters is by using system
configuration. You can either search for
system configuration or you can simply
start
msconfig.exe. There are a number of tabs
available inside of system
configuration. You have general, boot,
services, startup, and tools. Under the
general tab, you can select how Windows
will start up, whether it's a normal
startup, one that uses diagnostics, or
you can specify exactly what loads
during the startup process. Under the
boot option, you can decide exactly
which operating system you would like to
start. There may be multiple operating
systems on your computer. You can choose
safe boot from this option and choose
what type of safe boot you would like to
use. Or you can change different
options. For example, you can get rid of
the graphical user interface when it's
booting. You can create a log during the
boot process and other detailed boot
options. The services tab is another way
that we can look at all of the services
that begin when this computer is
starting up and we can decide how this
service will run when we start our
computer. There's also a startup tab
that does a similar process for the
individual applications that load when
you log in. This used to be a separate
part of the system configuration utility
and now that function is built into our
task manager. And lastly, there is the
tools tab where you can launch different
utilities available inside of Windows
such as the event viewer, internet
options, task manager, resource monitor,
and many
more. Our computers never seem to have
enough storage space on our hard drives
and our SSDs. One way that you can
easily clean out these drives is by
running disk cleanup. This is a quick
way to categorize the type of data that
is stored on your system and be able to
easily and safely delete information
that you no longer need. You can see
there are a number of categories already
predefined within disc cleanup such as
downloaded program files, temporary
internet files, Windows error reports,
and other categories. A quick way to
start disc cleanup is running clean
mgr.exe. When we start looking at disc
cleanup, you can see the different areas
where you might select files. Things
like downloaded program files, temporary
internet files, recycle bin, and
temporary files themselves. Notice on
this computer, we have 1.56 GB of
temporary files on this computer. If I
select that category, you can see it
changes at the bottom how much disk
space we're going to free up. and we can
free up 1.58 with the different settings
that I've selected here. We will click
okay to perform that. It tells us, are
you sure you want to permanently delete
these files? And we will click yes to go
through the process of finding all of
these files and deleting them from our
storage
drives. If you have a Windows computer
that's using a traditional spinning hard
drive, then you might want to look into
the defrag utility. This stands for disk
defragmentation. Whenever we're storing
files onto our drives, it keeps the
files separated into different sections.
One way that you can improve the read
and write performance of your system is
by taking all of those different
fragments of files and bring them back
together into one contiguous format. I
mentioned spinning hard drives because
if you're using an SSD or solid state
drive, there's no need to perform a disk
defragmentation. An SSD is able to
access all of these file fragments
without having to wait for a delay as a
disc spins underneath. This means that
we don't need to do any type of disc
defragmentation if we're using an
SSD. If you go into the drive
properties, you can run a graphical
frontend for disc defragmentation where
you can simply use the Windows graphical
interface to select the options you
would like and to perform the
defragmentation. You can also perform
this at the command line using the
defrag command and specifying the volume
that you would like to use for the def
fragmentation. Here's the graphical
front end of the defrag utility. You can
see that it has performed an analysis of
this drive and finds that 98% of the
space is efficient. We probably do not
need to perform a def fragmentation at
98%. But if you really wanted to get
that extra 2% out of that system, you
could click the optimize button to
perform the defragmentation. This
performs an update on my system every
week. It analyzes and optimizes anything
that may need to be changed. But if
you'd like to modify that, there's an
option within the utility to change all
of those configuration settings.
When you save configuration options for
an application, you may be wondering
where Windows stores all of those
details. Windows stores that information
and so much more within the Windows
registry. And you can view and edit the
Windows registry by using the
regggedit.exe
utility. If you start looking around
inside of your registry, you'll see
there is a lot of information to go
through. That's because information is
stored here about the kernel, the
services, the applications you're using,
and so much more. Because this is such a
critical resource for Windows, it's very
important that you don't make any
changes without knowing exactly what
you're doing. And it's always a good
idea to back up that portion of the
registry before making any changes so
that you can easily revert back to the
previous configuration.
When you first start the registry
editor, user account control recognizes
that this is a utility that can make
some significant changes to your system.
So, it confirms that you really do want
this app to make changes to this device.
And we will choose yes. When you first
start the registry editor, it's
completely blank in the main menu and
you have a number of different folders
that you can expand on the left side.
Each of these folders starts with the
word H key and that stands for handle to
registry key. The different categories
are for classes root, current user,
local machine, users, and current
config. Let's look into one of these
categories. We'll go to HQ local
machine. This is a popular one. We'll
choose the software option. We'll also
choose the Microsoft option. Let's
scroll all the way down to the bottom
where the Windows options might be.
We'll expand out Windows and the one
that I'd like to see is all of the
options underneath current version.
These are the individual registry
entries. You can see the entries have a
name, a type, and the data associated
with those. For example, we can see that
information about your common files are
stored in a program files common files.
And if we wanted to modify that inside
of the operating system, we simply need
to change the registry key and restart
our computer. I also mentioned that
before we make changes in the registry,
it might be a good idea to back these
up. So under the file pulld down menu,
there's an option to export a registry
key or section of a registry key, which
is referred to as a hive. We will select
what we would like to change whether
it's the entire registry or a registry
hive and then we can save that as
separate files either on this computer
or a separate storage drive. If later on
you need to restore that information
that you've saved, you can simply run
that registry file and it will rewrite
that information back into your
registry.